[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
maïté ce qui est devant nous mais paraît
relativement simple aujourd'hui on va
mêler une recette familiale pas grand
chose et on va faire de la langue de
boeuf ou la langue de boeuf à leur
autrefois on en mangeait chez les
grands-parents un homard je sais les
grands-parents manger c'est le dit marc
chollou c'était le plat de fait graves à
deux pays s'étaient plutôt au delà de
luxe c'est le pas de lui c'était le
plein du 10 mars quand c'était la fête
au village quand on tuer le cochon quand
on faisait toutes les fêtes on faisait
de la langue de bain parce que dans le
scope ce que carey minya il y avait deux
soupes l'euro si le sens où l'on retire
your ride en bon français ça veut dire
que la démence et par le bouilli la
santé l'europe y est ça c'était la
source
un bon voilà rien très bien nous elle
nous expliquer c'est comme ça paraît un
peu compliquée à priori alors ça c'est
une langue de boeuf moyenne pour lier
leur histoire il ya beaucoup plus gros
en général il faut faire 20 tranche de
vingt trois branches dans une langue de
boeuf là on les fait pareil alors long
métrage où l'on voulait faire
relativement peu de clients norbert sur
les plans régis menoux bon maïté vous
nous disiez la langue mais est ce que
c'est un plat cher aujourd'hui pas du
tout pas du tout non c'est la langue de
boeuf kg 28 39 kg au contraire simple
économie
simplement il faut du temps pour la
cuire cétacés louis besoin que tout seul
voilà et qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour
commencer on va faire un bon bouillon
pour la cuire au four du poireau du
céleri butin et du laurier des carottes
de l'hogneau 2 échalotes la tomate
on verra après et peu de persil et la
langue bien évidemment non et qu'est ce
que vous allez faire avec tout ça la
banque pour commencer voilà je vais
mettre de l'eau dans un pot pour la
cuire
alors on prône signé l'accord un premier
jeu mais la langue en premier la langue
un premier la langue dans l'eau tiède
là après je vais le sel le gros sel de
gros sel je vais bien ça l'est parce
qu'il faut qu'elle soit bien droit et
maintenant les légumes
oui alors amis rognon découvrira avec
des coûts de support
c'est comme dans tout les bouillons au
fond c'est toujours pareil et c'est
toujours pareil
exactement le mystère voilà pour ce port
cap de couture l'oignon froid ça va vous
avez mis de l'eau froide ou nourrir et
de pompiers
partent plus vite je vends de même
regard oui à voir au lac et la carotte
par tiers la trousse 1 440 du ter et du
laurier ça toujours valide à vendre mais
oui une feuille de feuilles de paye est
une des belles
les voilà je vais écrasé deux gousses
d'ail
oui ou qu'elle donne bien du goût
n'avoir pas perçu à ces jeux notamment à
son programme elle peut aussi et bien
faire et je l'espère si c'est bien le
frisé donne pas de goût - ce charles
joris verser des frais voilà
et bien c'est bon et c'est tout là je
pense que c'est tout on arrive je vais
bien ouvrir
oui et il fera que ça puisqu'on me
rendent très longtemps il faut la
surveiller
il faut quand on plante un couteau il
faut que ce soit qui se sentent bien
dans quelques secondes vers 2h30 deux
heures ou 10 au minimum
oui alors déjà on pourrait envisager une
science dont qui l'accompagnera oui on
va faire une sauce aux câpres
pourquoi du jambon a été d'autant plus
qu'il est beau alors le jambon c'est la
base de tout les hachis donc c'est pour
faire mon achi est assis pour quoi faire
vous et par une sauce pour toute la base
de la sauce abdallah pour la langue je
vais voir alors cette base de sauce ou
la fête donc avec du jambon depuis dix
ans
et puis quoi d'autre l'échalote delahaye
de la ventrèche et après j ajouterai
c'est finalement des câpres
la première des choses ça va être de
très belles tranches de jean dreuil
n'est pas si facile aux obsèques
on va y arriver oui tension ne pas vous
couper la nounou ses couteaux qui
coupent bien vrai justement faut pas
qu'il a coupé trop loin je le réserve
ans on va prendre ces maisons parce
qu'il en faut pas car même les quantités
la jurée quan on a fait que vous enlevez
la peau qu'elle appelle un mauvais
rapport je mets ça là je mets ça là je
me fais mon petit ménage - oui ma
rentrée chien autant déjà un peu plus
lorsque vanessa lucic a baissé moins 7
et après ça que ce que vous allez faire
avec tout ça je vais le passer à la
moulinette vous passez toutes ensemble
bien sûr jamais la ventrèche
voilà le jambon pour l'échalote d'abord
que sympa surtout un peu plus oui un
petit peu d'ail aussi la moulinette de
cette douce de vous associer rugby c'est
bojan bon c'est dommage de lâcher ça sur
le cibona l'inca secours
oui mais voilà il veut on arrête dans
une licence avec la langue ça sera pas
mauvais non plus ne gâche rien
ça y est c'est bon et avec cela si
qu'est ce qu'on va en faire
alors maintenant je vais le cuir bien
entendu je me met ça dans une cocotte où
j'ai mis de la graisse de canard à
chauffer le fait qu'en principe elle est
brûlante et les brûlantes et elle l'est
voilà je fais cuire mon petit chien
jaune qu'ils allaient boire et linehan
pourquoi nous rien du tout parce que la
ventrèche est assaisonné le jambon aussi
oui voilà c'est bien joli ça va chez
ovum blanc vous dire oui seulement avant
il vous tient m'en vais là oui c'est
merveilleux avant je vais vous livrer un
petit peu ce fonds de sauce oui avec
quoi avec de la farine de bien entendu
ah bon c'est le moment de la mer pour
épaissir un petit peu ça pourrait
vouloir lassaussois quand même assez
haute
oui parce que ça va ça va crier leurs
banderilles mais là il faudrait
construire des milliers
alors comme ça inter milan s'incline un
petit nuage de farine là comme ça
n'occupe plus relevée qu'on ne s'occupe
plus brillé la source ifo alors là en
principe si bien ce très bien et votre
vin maïté je crois c'est du vin blanc
d'abord de lui-même billets de train de
bouillir l'école de lembeye comme du
rouge qui est pas là mais hors voyons
sur leur mur brûlé oui non c'est pas la
peine offrir à brûler des gens
voilà je fais vite revu vos papiers de
jumeaux ferme ml et voilà et c'est tout
et vous ajoutez un bon demi litre de vin
blanc et vous allez laisser sa réduire
majorité tout doucement sans mettre les
caps pour la même
non parce que là ça c'est loin d'être
fini on finira après pour acheter un
petit coup d'oeil à la langue en rire
des scellés qui tend au
elle a bien réduit très bien elle est
cuite up joly on va la sortir
là vous allez la servir comme ça je
trouve pas ça très élégant vieux non je
vais l'appeler on apprend ça fait joli
quand même
mais oui je ne compare pas à s'en va
comme un gant comme un gant parce que
comme le break un peu près des canards
oui regardez ça mais là on peut
l'attirer à deux je crois regarde le
regardez regardez ça si c'est pas joli à
les envoyer se faisait ça y est voilà
et alors là qu'est ce qu'on va en faire
on va la garder au chaud en finançant la
semaine aux chaunois la laisser comme ça
oui c'est même pas besoin de le garder
au chaud et parce qu'on va la remettre
dans la source est bien chaud devoir y
aller elle est belle à la très bien et
est ce que encore quelque chose à faire
avec cette saison va finir on va finir
autres sauf c'est à dire je vais
regarder mans achi ah c'est bon allez
zou les uns blanc oui et je vais
rajouter mon bouillon oui la voyez et
c'est joli
je vais rajouter montguyon de toit
fuyante que vous aviez fait par ailleurs
c'est pas le bouillon de cuisson non non
non non non non au tableau lyon vous
aviez en réserve parce que hughes et
allen est toujours y avoir une guerre on
garde toujours du bon bouillon et c'est
tout et notre source est pratiquement
terminée on n'a plus qu'à couper la
langue est lui-même par an mais là je me
demande si vous vous trompez pas parce
que vous me parlez d'une sauce au cacao
par les caf mais relégable
merci micheline alors qu'en syrie les
mettre tout de suite voilà merci
micheline rolla là après on dit qu'on
travaille sans filet nous on a défilé
ici
la voilà il en a enlevé ou lors de
cuillères hop parce qu'il faut que ce
soit un petit peu vinaigrée oui c'est
parfait et c'est tout voilà l'éclat
puissant là on va mettre la langue et
qui va finir donner du goût à tout ça
vous la mettez entière ou là leur groupe
elabor je vais la couper en tranches
là alors commencé à la quitter comme ça
voilà aujourd'hui d'époque seberg et
vous là ça devient appétissant 1
voilà ça maintenant c'est pas très bon
ah non on va laisser et voilà voyez
c'est pas la mort du petit cheval et
cette langue ici dans la sauce on va
s'entraîner un peu du goût des saveurs
danse et vous savez vous pouvez la
garder huit jours cette source
ah oui et une 5e bonne vous la
réchauffer avec la langue
le tout prix goncourt jours comme ça
voilà terminé ces prêts peu à manger on
pourrait faire éventuellement une autre
sociaux n'attend pas ce que vous avez
dit qu'on pouvait la manger aussi de
prendre toute façon oui une vinaigrette
peut-être mérité un peu arrangé un peu
arrangé c'est-à-dire avec l'un a bon
goût ce voyage du père sied de la leur
aussi la wii
donc c'est pas une vinaigrette ordina
prélever des autoritaires ne m'en donne
un signal
[Musique]
vous lecteurs
c'est bon pourquoi est ce que vous le
lâcher la au hachoir ses meilleurs ses
meilleurs et bien mélanger aux piercings
et oui et là vous avez l'intention de
lâcher aussi bien sur le voile à madère
si micheline il est bien dur il vient de
mourir alors je mets la vinaigrette
non je la perds c'est la persillade
ensuite lui qui est juste comme il faut
un tout petit peu moins lui parce que de
façon il va se mélanger à mener le reste
va se briser l' avantage voilà bus et
les poivres mi-dure mi-mollet voilà la
de l'huile du vinaigre
très peu de vinaigre et vous ne verrez
rien du tout pas unir pour trois ans
arnaud non mais moins qu'en janvier un
maniaque mais là c'est bon et bien nous
avons maintenant deux sauces
d'accompagnement il n'y a plus qu'à
présenter les pl oui et vous allez voir
ça va être joli de recettes bien
appétissante maïté de votre côté qu'est
ce qui se passe ça fume d'avoir ça fume
ça c'est la sauce au beurre avec apple
vous nappe est un peu mieux en mieux la
haye oui regardez la façon car c'était
très bien pour rendre amoureux c'est
vrai ça a peut-être gens surveillent ce
alors vous a par contre sachez vous juin
faire alors très bien vous aurez raison
dans ses gérants côté c'est la langue un
peu tiède oui peut être la vinaigrette
améliorer la langue que vous mettiez
pour les agresseurs pour les entrées
voilà alors leur humanité un plat cher
non pas du tout pas du tout chez un
plein bon dans la vous en avez afin de
convaincre
je pense tout compris oui / non t'as
plus rien entendu alors à part pour les
déjeuners en famille oui
regardons les repas entre amis quand on
est nombreux comme on veut on peut
l'accueillir la veille la veille et la
réchauffer ça dure pendant 3 jours 3 4
joue plus on réchauffe meilleur safe et
bien vous auriez tort de vous en priver
à bientôt un appétit au revoir au revoir
[Musique]